Wolverine is one the most popular comic
book characters but how did he get
all that metal on his bones?
And what about those claws?
Let's over think this a bit shall we?
Hey people, Trace here for Dnews with
some interesting insight into the man
known as Logan.
Wolverine comes out in
theaters this week and we thought,
[mimics sound effects]
Okay we thought that but we also thought,
"I wonder if there's any scientific basis
for this?"
[mimics sound effects]
After some mediocre X-men
films came out in the early 2000s people got
Wolverine fever and have since been
debating a scientific basis
for Wolverine's super strong adamantium
bones and claws and stuff,
the same debate comic nerds have been
having for decades.
If we're gonna give Wolverine an adamantium
skeleton with today's technology,
what would we use?
Wolverine's claws and
skeleton use adamantium for their
indestructible-ness
and though it is a fictional elements we
do have some cool stuff that's a lot
like it.
Adamantium is an indestructible stuff
that was once a solid.
That's how it gets its name.
Adamantine
means unbreakable.
While diamond was once considered the hardest
naturally occurring substance and you
know it is really hard
it's not very strong.
If you were to hit a diamond with a hammer,
it would shatter.
Tungsten is another option.
It's tough
but its heavy and unfortunately it's
water soluble so his claws would dissolve
in his blood.
Not so good.
Titanium is strong and light but
with the melting point of 1,933 Calvin, we
can't really liquefy it easily to coat Wolvy's
bones wihtout
also liquefying his skin.
There are strong, tough nanomaterials - alloys
and other specially cultivated substances.
For example,
wurtzite boron nitrate
a super strong crystalline substance with
a hugh melting point,
but unfortunately, it's an irritant.
So if Logan deployed his claws, he'd cause
cell damage to the eyes and respiratory systems
to anyone in
the vicinity.
DAMN IT!
I'm thinking the best bet would probably be
aggregated diamond nano-rods.
If you take graphene and you roll it into
a tube and then press
it together,
it's super strong, it has a high melting
point - it's actually stronger than
diamonds - and it wouldn't
kill anyone by being exposed to air.
Which is a plus.
In the movies, Wolverine has adamantium
injected
into his body so it could coat his bones.
And
thanks to its healing factor he survives
where others would have not.
That's heavy doc.
So how can we get these diamond nano-rods
into Logan?
We kinda can't.
Once melted, the substance would cease to
be a network of diamonds
nano-tubes so this would just maybe work for
his claws.
What would we do to cover his bones?
A company called Liquid Metal produces an
amorphous metal alloy used in everything from
space technology, to cell phones & toys,
and their metals have the moldability of
plastic and twice the strength of
titanium, which is pretty good.
The problem is liquid metal is not a liquid.
It's a solid alloy of at least three medals:
zirconium, titanium, nickel, copper or beryllium.
So while it's great for commercial applications,
it's not exactly
awesome for a superhero.
He'd have to keep sharpening his claws and
the metal has high elasticity.
So instead of a badass, rampaging Wolverine
with metal bone covers,
we'd have Gumby or Pokey.
Or maybe we should skip the liquid coating
the bones thing and leave
that to the realm the comic books.
Are you heading out to see the movie
this weekend?
Tell us what you think, no spoilers!
And we'll see you next time on Dnews.
Thanks a lot for watching everybody.
We do this for you.
So thanks.
Bye.